Sassie beats is far from a household
name but her role in the upcoming
Deadpool sequel might just change all
that in the scant five years that beats
his IMDB profile has been active she's
racked up a respectable number of
credits
here's white Domino from Deadpool -
looks so familiar wolves zazzy started
her career like most other up-and-coming
actors in their mid-20s by playing high
school students wolves is the age old
urban tale of a young man named Anthony
who uses his prowess on the basketball
court to escape a far more complicated
home life beats is Victoria Lee's love
interest whose arc revolves around her
desperate desire to know all the parts
of him that he keeps hidden shot during
the summer of 2015
wolves is the project that let beats
give up her day job and pursue acting
full-time the film took a one-way ticket
to highbrow town by premiering at the
Tribeca Film Festival before being
picked up for distribution by IFC Films
Margot vs. Lily in 2016 Nike decided
that a cute diverse and surprisingly
well-made web series was the best way to
promote their workout clothes and margot
vs lily was the result as part of the
better for it women's campaign
this was Nikes first scripted show and
it got a nice amount of positive buzz in
part because the commercial elements
were integrated well into the narrative
[Music]
beats plays Ally best friend and
roommate - Margot a snarky millennial
with the chip on her shoulder who lives
and plots in the shadow of her
internet-famous fitness guru sister Lily
easy this Netflix original lacks the
buzz or prestige of some of their other
high-profile shows like stranger things
or house of cards but easy does have
that rambling inequality that seems to
fit nicely within beaches filmography
this sexy ensemble drama follows a chain
of interlinking friends navigating the
ups and downs of their intimate
relationships Beats plays Noelle a sweet
and supportive stoner who's dating an
amateur Brewer named Jeff played by dave
Franco who has ambitions of starting an
illegal brewery with his more
conservative brother just imagine you
were pregnant and you about any of this
what would you do what would you do
I want freak out exactly
Atlanta much ink has been spilled about
the groundbreaking Atlanta Donnell
Glover's emmy-winning MC Escher painting
of an urban drama beats plays van a
young mother in love with Glover's urn
the father of her daughter who it turns
she's completely enamored with and
totally frustrated by due to his
underachieving Spacey charismatic
brilliance oh you're doing that weird
sad boy face that's just my face this
role is tailor-made to make use of all
the beads has to offer as an actor and
is likely the reason she was on the
Deadpool creative team's radar to begin
with Geo storm even though her role is
small 2017 SGO storm mark Spitz's first
appearance at a high-profile film she
plays Dana a cyber security analyst and
friend of max played by Jim Sturgess the
disaster flick was unfortunately reamed
by critics but beats was still able to
inject some expositional technobabble in
moments levity opposite Sturges and when
she appears in Deadpool 2 it won't be
her first time at the blockbuster rodeo
the boss if you can make it through this
squirmy January 2018 dramatization of a
real-life workplace harassment you'll
see beats go from an efficient and
helpful professional to confused then
alarmed then panicked as her boss
proceeds to violate her space completely
this wasn't just another acting job
it's a PSA executive produced by Beats
co-star David Schwimmer
it's among a series of short films
released online designed to raise
awareness about rain the nation's
largest anti-sexual violence
organization Deadpool two months before
anyone got to see her in action is
Domino beats was part of the vast media
machine surrounding the Deadpool sequel
her casting was announced to be a Ryan
Reynolds Twitter with a character poster
and her arrival quickly generated a ton
of buzz in the world of comics Domino
aka Neena Thurman debuted in the pages
of x-force number eight in 1992 her
power to affect the probability of any
event within her line of sight is the
result of a government experiment she's
joined various mercenary bands and also
rolled solo throughout her history beats
may seem an odd choice to play the
pistol-packing motorcycle reving
mercenary mutant but her fresh take
might be just what the role needs thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]